la direction d'un orchestre peut-elle
être démocratique
ça c'est la grosse question bien sûr que
toute réunion d'un groupe qui travaille
dans le même sens
peut-être démocratique mais avec des
fonctions naturellement différentes
le chef d'orchestre a pour mission de
transmettre
donc il doit travailler une conception
et ils doivent servir la pensée du
compositeur et doit en fonction de ce
que souhaite le compositeur transmettre
à travers son propre filtre la
conception qu'il a construites ou aux
musiciens qu'il dirige et donc chaque
musicien doit avoir le sentiment que le
chef d'orchestre fait tout pour qu'ils
exercent leur métier le mieux possible
donc ce sont pas tellement des rapports
de si vous voulez ou deux de démiurge a
asservi l'oua de dictateur annie bel
guen ne sais pas ça ce sont des gens qui
ont chacun une fonction et qui doivent
travailler au service de la musique
voilà alors quelques fois il y en a qui
se trompent peut évidemment y en a qui
se met devant la musique au lieu de
rester derrière
mais avant tout c'est un échange de de
qualité et de complémentarité avec
évidemment quelqu'un qui dirige mais on
relate la vie à c'est normal d'avoir des
gens qui dirigent ce com com vous monter
à cheval
le cheval peut être un pur sang et il
faut lui montrer le chemin que vous
voulez qu'ils qu'ils accomplissent
[Musique]